[Musique]
au printemps 1940 la Grande-Bretagne est
proche de la catastrophe militaire piégé
sur les plages de dkirk le corps
expéditionnaire britannique affronte une
situation impossible avec l'arrivée
massive des forces d'attaque
hitlériennes on a vécu l'enfer les
tripes le sang les cordes déché par les
bombes et les mitrailleurs qui battait
des centaines d'hommes c'était
absolument
épouvantable lesouas étai équipés de
sirènes qui hlai pendant leur descente
dans le but de nous
effrayer et ça marchait on se faisait
bombarder à longueur de journée tous ces
cadavr on priait pour être dans la bonne
file un de mes amis a été touché par des
éclat d' qui lui ont arraché les yeux de
la tête il est mort presque
instantanément
quita
les avions piquaient sur nous les
soldats m'ont crié que diable
faites-vous ici mademoiselle ils m'ont
porté sur leur dos le long de la
plage pour la Grande-Bretagne la guerre
semblait être finie avant même d'avoir
commencé le noyau de l'armée britannique
est sur le point de se faire éliminer
sans aucune possibilité de
s'échapper on est resté sur la plage
pendant 48 he sans nourriture sans eau
il avait nulle part aller se cacher les
avions de la luftff nous survolaient on
était des cibles faciles on espérait
juste qu'il nous rate un navire hôital a
explosé une bombe est tombée dans la
cheminée et a fait éclater le bâtiment
en morceaux l'eau était pleine de jeunes
en train de mourir ou déjà mort mais le
capitaine a dit on ne peut pas arrêter
messieur on peut pas
arrêter finalement on a atteint la
Manche et on s'est tous senti
extrêmement
soulagé une fois à Douvre on a embrassé
le sol et on a pleuré toutes les larmes
de notre
[Musique]
corps en hommage au courage de ces
soldats britanniques et de ceux qui les
ont secouru les grands reportages vous
présentent ce soir l'histoire d'un
sauvetage épique que nous ne devons
jamais oublier raconté par ceux qui
l'ont vécu l'Opération Dynamo est le
moment culminant d'un des plus grands
sauvetages de tous les temps
des centaines de navires britanniques
dont beaucoup de bateaux privés
traversent la Manche pour secourir les
militaires en détresse plongeant
courageusement dans le feu de
l'action j'ai connu l'enfer je pense
encore chaque jour et je rêve chaque
nuit à C jour là où j'ai traversé tant
d'épreuv afin de pouvoir vivre j'ai 99
ans et 4 mois maintenant et je suis
toujours
là chaque matin en réveillant
j p ça m'étonne d'être encore
vivant j'en rêve encore toutes les
nuits je suis le seul survivant connu de
mon bataillon qui soit encore en vie un
parmi des
millions plus personne ne souvient de ça
je parle à des gens qui me disent
c'était pendant quelle guerre c'est
l'attitude du monde
d'aujourd'hui les éc d'aujourdhui n'
Jama entendu par
de non plus les événements de dunkk sont
tellement importants du point de vue
politique et militaire mondial ça
m'étonne que les gens ne s'en
souviennent pas jusqu'à la sortie du
film le grand public n'avait
généralement aucune idée de ce que
représentait der ceux qui savaient ce
qui s'y est passé voyent ça comme une
anecdote de l'histoire britannique qui
s'est produite avant que les États-Unis
ent en guerre pour nous sauver c'est
beaucoup plus important que ça c'est une
histoire universelle de survie un
miracle en ce sensautant de soldats sont
revenus vivant alors qu'à première vue
ça semblait peu probable le fait que ces
militaires britannique soit rentré chez
eux signifiait que la Grande-Bretagne
n'avait pas signé un traité de paix avec
Hitler qu'elle n'avait pas à se rendre
si les troupes avaient été anéanti la
guerre aurait été finie et on en
subirait encore les conséquences
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de gloire dans
la
guerre
[Musique]
je suis né en 1918 dans une famille assz
pvre ma mère n'était pas une femme
agréable j'étais incontrôlable il m'
donc dit que j'irais à l'asile du Do
Bernardo j suis resté de l'âge de 5 ans
jusquà 8 ans puis je suis allé au foyer
pour enfant de norood pendant 2 ans et
celui de
ensite mon
enfance croyez-moi vous ne pouvez pas
comprendre la vie à cette époque c'était
dur très
dur je me suis enrôlé dans l'armée
territoriale à l'âge de 18 ans je l'ai
fait parce que la bière ne coûtait pas
cher à la cantine et parce que les
filles aimaient les hommes en
uniforme je ne me suis pas vraiment
enrôlé pour devenir soldat je suis entré
dans l'armée territoriale à Brixton en
tant que canonnier antichar je
m'installais devant l'infanterie et ma
tâche était de tirer sur les chars
d'assaut je faisais du vélo avec un ami
sur le terrain communal de
Wimbledon un sergent recruteur nous a
demandé voulez-vous vous engager dans
l'armée on a dit oui quel âge as-tu j'ai
répondu 16 ans il a refusé parce que
j'étais trop jeune attendez je lui ai
dit ce n'est pas vrai j'ai 17 ans et il
m'a
enrôlé ma vie n'était rien c'est pour ça
que je me suis engag dans la marine je
n'avais pas tout à fait 17
ans un jeune de C ge trouve ça
merveilleux porter un
[Musique]
uniforme
je suis né en Belgique à
enverse quand la guerre a éclaté il a
fallu qu'on parte les allemsé notre
maison on a d tout laisser derrière nous
je n'avais
que la Guer été déclaré le 3 septembre
1939 j'ai é mobilisé la fin du mois de
septembre donc pas mal dès le début
j'étais
conscr j'ai bien vu la guerre venir mon
père m'a conseillé de quitter l'armée et
de m'engager dans
l'aviation il fallait se soumettre à un
examen médical pour l'armée de l'air
comme je portais des lunettes j'ai
échoué à l'examen ça m'a sauvé la vie
parce que la majorité de mes camarades
n'ont pas survécu à la guerre mes
lunettes m'ont sauvé la
vie au début on voyait ça comme une
aventure imagine pas comment ça
serait personne n'aurait pu deviner ce
qui allait se
[Musique]
passer la seconde guerre mondiale
deviendra Leit nation le plus brutal et
le plus destructeur de
l'histoire à la suite de l'invasion
allemande de la Pologne en septembre
1939 le corps expéditionnaire
britannique est envoyé en
Europe au début de la guerre en 1939 le
corps expéditionnaire britannique s'est
rendu en France il était composé de
jeunes hommes qui n'avaient jamais été à
l'étranger de leur vie cétait incroyable
pour eux monter à bord de bateau et de
train traverser la France se ruer aux
fenêtres pour voir de quoi avait l'air
un pays étranger comme il ne se passait
pas encore grandchose ils en ont profité
pour connaître les Français découvrir la
cuisine française et faire des chos
qu'ils n'avaient jamais fait avant car
ils étaient loin de chez eux c'était une
sorte d'aventure pour ces
jeunesl la GrandeBretagne ne se fâche
pas facilement et n'a jamais voulu de
cette guerre maintenant qu'il nous a été
imposé nous sommes déterminés à la mener
jusqu'au bout peu importe les sacrifices
requis or ce sont ceux qui font les plus
grand sacrifice les combattants qui sont
les plus
enthousiastes on a visité le château de
bras un grand château c'était très
beau on a effectué la traversée le jour
de Noël pour accoster à Cherbourg en
France le lendemain c'est comme ça qu'on
a
passé on est arrivé dans un village
appel g courour près de la frontière
belge je faisais partie d'un bataillon
de mitrailleur c'était très différent de
la vie à la maison avec ma
m les soldats reçoivent des rations
alimentaires conçu pour répondre à leurs
besoins
nutritionnels il nous donit une boî de
bis pouri tout ceon avait à manger pour
la
journis pas deord il les ETAM pour arver
à les
[Musique]
avis beaucoup
d'énergier du R ilit mie pas demander ce
qu'il y avait
ded
[Musique]
le corps expéditionnaire qui débarque en
Europe en 1939 est une armée totalement
mécanisée mais son entraînement
scandaleusement inadéquat le r incapable
de combattre l'armée allemande bien
mieux préparé il manquait d'entraînement
ce n'était pas de vrais soldat
pratiquement aucun d'entre eux n'avait
déjà
combattu c'est étonnant mais plusieurs
de ces soldats n'avaient littéralement
jamais utilisé d'arme à feu arriv en
France on savait à pe près de quel côté
de la mitrailleuse la balle sorta on
savait marcher au
pasruction de be il nous don un fus on
peu et il nous camion quiitêtre le NRE
jusqu la
fin d'endre les des un des autres sur
les de combat je pvais tirer démonter
une arme réassembl je pouvais même tenir
la barre du bateau il fallait savoir
tout faire
en mai 1940 la situation en Europe
semble désastreuse l'armée de Hitler
lance des attaques dévastatrices contre
la France la Belgique et les
Pays-Bas c'est en mai que les combats
ont vraiment débuté les Allemands ayant
gagné du terrain le corps
expéditionnaire britannique a avancé
pour aller les affronter à un point
préétabli en Belgique
les Britanniques n'avaient pas reçu
l'autorisation d'entrer dans ce pays la
Belgique était censé rester neutre et ne
s'impliquer dans la guerre que si elle
était
attaqu Belg les Britan Françis le en
France pour rendre
renre le premier endroit où on est allé
cétait Bruxelles laù on trouva
éta été compltement évacu CIV
t
on est monté dans le train à enverse
mais il n'avançait pas on est donc
descendu et on a traversé la Belgique
pour aller jusqu'en France on a parcouru
toutes ces distance à
pied le Blitz a débuté le 10 mai c'est
là qu'on a affronté les Allemands pour
la première
fois on a suivi la rivière tout au long
les Allemands étai de l'autre côté sur
can lu ont tiré sur les leurs on avait
un avion lzandre dans les airs qui
m'envoyait de l'information que je
transmettais à l'armée et j'ai fini par
trouver la cible et abattre leur
avion tout le monde s'attendait à ce que
chacun reste sur ses positions comme
durant la Première Guerre mondiale une
guerre d'usure avec très peu de
mouvement des soldats pensaient qu'ils
finiraient dans leur tranchée face aux
Allemands dans les leurs parce qu'ils
étaient habitués à ce genre
d'affrontement
ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé les
Allemands on monté cette attaque
incroyablement audacieuse à travers les
ardenes avec leur char d'assut les P qui
trans toutes les
défensesne naait cru qu'on pit franchir
une Z boisé avec des chars mais les
Allemands sont parvenus comme il n'
pratiquement aucune force défensive
derrière eux ils ont atteint la côte en
quelques jours à
peineaise
commun
àautorand
ob pas
faisuse du manque de communication entre
les armé britanniqu et français avant la
Bata de aucun des de Savit vraiment ce
que faisait
l'autre
can
si leur canon est tourné de l'autre côté
ce sont des alliés je lui ai répondu
d'accord
sergent quand des chars sont arrivés il
m'a dit sures
sal mais je voyais
pas d'accord attends un peu soudainement
ce sont eux qui ont commencé à nous
tirer dessus et à nous mettre en
pièce j'ai
pensé c'est épouvantable c'est
épouvantable mon can
qu minutes quand j'ai repris
connaissance j'ai entendu monsieur
monsieur on est vraiment désolé on pens
que vous étiez des Allemands cétait des
foutus français qu'il y avait dans ce
char d'ASS gros comme une maison il av
fait 17 victimes chez
les ils ont appris une leçon à l'avenir
non seulement les Alliés devraiil
communiquer beaucoup mieux entre eux
mais aussi au sein de leurs armées
respectives
[Musique]
les alliés sont incapables d'égaler la
force et la férocité des attaques éclair
allemandes face à la puissance aérienne
supérieure de la verm et à son
commandement unifié les Britanniques et
les Français ne sont tout simplement pas
à la
hauteur l'armée allemande était mieux
équipée mieux formé et plus
expérimenté tout leur armement était
meilleur que le nôtre ils avaient de
meilleur mitrailleus de meilleurs canon
et de meilleurs chars d'assaut il
gardaient toujours une longueur d'avance
sur nous ils avaient de plus gros chars
qui pouvaient tirer plus loin il
restaient hors de notre portée et nous
lanç une bu après
l'autre les défenses de Paris sont
complètement hermétiques les avions
ennemis rencontreront une barrière
d'acier qui protège le cœur palpitant de
la France la mer leçon de 1914 a donner
lieu à la construction de la célèbre
ligne magino kilomètr après kilomètres
les frontières Est et nordest de la
France sont jalonnés de tourelles
d'acier et de béton reliés sous terre
par de vastes salles souterraines ici
des armées entières peuvent être
cantonnées dans un environnement
confortable et
climatisé on ne passe pas tel est le cri
de guerre historique du soldat français
les tirs croisés des canons de la ligne
magino feront en sorte que la nouvelle
guerre mondiale ne se déroulera pas en
France les alliés sont incapables
d'endiguer l'avancée de l'ennemi
dans la ville de warmou à 27 km de
Dunkirk les troupes britanniques sont
facilement maîtrisé par les forces
allemandes alors que les forces de
Hitler avancent à la vitesse de l'éclair
sur le territoire français les Alliés
semblent de plus en plus
désemparés ça prenait beaucoup de
courage je n jamais vu de
lâche ce n'est que plusieurs années as
don que la psychiatrie militaire
deviendra un élément essentiel des soins
offerts au soldats ces soldats qui sont
revenus du front je sais exactement ce
qu'il ressentaiit j'ai longtemps eu des
flashback mais je n'ai jamais reçu de
traitement ou quoi que ce soit d'autres
du genre personne n'allait en thérapie
pour ça on apprenait à vivre avec je
n'avais pas besoin de thérapie je dois
dire que les hommes de cette époque là
étai bien différents de ceux
d'aujourd'hui une thérapie un coup de
pied au derrière oui ces histoires de
consultation c'est des conneries d'abord
il n'y avait personne à consulter du
moins pas
[Musique]
officiellement moins nombreux moins bien
équipés et mal dirigés les Alliés
désespérés battent en retraite à
l'approche de la machine de guerre
[Musique]
nazie
leurs attaques clair avaient permis aux
Allemands d'encercler l'armée
britannique dans le nord de la
France les chars d'assau allemand ayant
pénétré jusquà la côte le corps
expéditionnaire britannique était
effectivement encclé avant même que les
combats vraiment débutés les
Britanniques étai déjà en difficulté et
il était clair qu'ils allai devoir
battre en
retraite les Allemands nous ont encerclé
tout s passé très vite la se possible
c'était la mer à ce moment-là donkerk
était le seul endroit par où les
Britanniques pouvaient
s'échapper une voiture de l'étatmajor
allemand passa sur la route la
patrouille a tiré sur le conducteur
l'officier assis à l'arrière a sauté
hors de la voiture et s'est enfui mais
il a laissé sur le
siège
casque sa ceinture avec son
louur et une
mallette qui a immédiatement ét
transporté au quartier général de
division
elle contenait les plans pour le corps
militaire allemand qui devait
attaquer ça leurait donné de jours de
grâce ce qui a permis au citoyens
français de quitter la ville de dkerk
qui avait été lourdement bombardé et aux
soldats français de la barricader pour
être en mesure de la
défendre la situation devient rapidement
désespérée les chars allemands ayant
atteint la manche après avoir franchi la
ligne maginau sans difficulté les armées
françaises et belges battent en retraite
chacune de son côté de la frontière il
ne reste plus qu'une seule option pour
le corps expéditionnaire britannique se
retirer jusqu'à
donkerirk vaincu et humiliés les alliés
sont acculés au pied du mur la ridition
semble inévitable tout porte à croire
que les Allemands ont remporté la guerre
en
Europe cette débacle incroyable car
c'est bien ce que c'était une écrasante
défaite semblait sonner le glas de
l'armée
britannique comme elle était déjà
coincée sur plusieurs fronts les
Allemands n'avaient plus qu'à compléter
la courbe pour l'encercler complètement
et dans ce cas-là comment aurait-elle pu
faire autre chose que de
le général nous a dit que personne ne
pouvait nous aider pour moi la guerre
était
perdue on disait qu'ils all envahir la
GrandeBretagne que tout était fini je me
demandais comment on aurait pu encore
gagner à ce stade on avait tout perdu
l'armée britannique au complet et tout
son
équipement c'est dans le CH que le cor
expéditionnaireige
vers Brit REC il devient clair pour le
commandant chef du cor expéditionnaire
que si la GrandeBretagne veut continuer
à se battre elle doit organiser une
évacuation c'est aussi évident que cette
évacuation peut uniquement se faire par
donk car tous les autres P sont tombés
l'un après l'autre au mains des
Allemands le seul qui reste encore entre
nos mains c'estk les soldats
britanniques ignorent encore pourquoi il
Batt en
retraite on savait pas ce qui se passait
il faisait nuit on a marché marché et
marché jusqu'à brune on a fini par
décider de se rendre jusqu'à l'endroit
d'où venait cette fumée d'un
kerque on a chargé les troupes
françaises de retenir les Allemands
pendant notre retraite on a ensuite
roulé jusqu'aux à bord de la panne il
était censé y avoir quelqu'un qui nous y
rejoindrait et qui nous dirait où aller
bien entendu quand on est arrivé il n'y
avait personne on a marché jusque dans
la mer l'eau à peu près jusqu'à la
poitrine les avions de la volaient
audessus de la plage en
mitraillant il n'y avait pas de navire
pas de bateau du tout ils nous ont fait
sortir de l'eau en nous disant que
chaque équipe d'artillerie devait se
débrouiller pour trouver son
chemin on avait pas de nourriture pas
d'au non plus j'ai dit à mon compagnon
Aby qu'est-ce qu'on va faire il m'a
répondu Harry il y a un vieux BF là on
va
l'abattre LEF
faisait je l'entendais je l'entend le
pvre vieux on l' tu d'un coup de
fus on a coupé quelques morceau on a
mangé un
steak comme
ça on a fini par rencontrer des soldats
du
régim il on és B eners nous il nous
Nour
hor avec l'ennemi à ses trouss l'armée
britannique en déroute poursuit son
chemin vers la
côte la consigne était que si on
trouvait un entrepôt des forces armées
on pouvait y entrer et se servir car les
Allemands allaient tout prendre de toute
façon j'y suis donc entré j'ai pris des
cigarettes mon cilote qui n'a jamais
conduit le camion a pris du whisky était
un écossais il est allé à l'arrière du
camion et il s'est saoulé je nai plus
revu avant qu'on arrive à la
[Musique]
plage des milliers de civils sans
défense s'enfui eux aussi pour échapper
à la mort les soldats britanniques sont
témoins d'innombrables scènes
[Musique]
d'horreur
il y avait tellement de réfugiés sur les
routes qui voulaient seulement partir de
là ça a donc beaucoup gêné la retraite
des Britanniques parce qu'il devait
partager la voie avec ces centaines de
milliers ces millions de civils qui
tenta aussi de
s'échapper c'était le chaos sur les
routes la situation était totalement
chaotique tout le monde se demandait ce
qui allait arriver mais personne ne le
savait onait pas le choix de continuer
mais les Français ont beaucoup
souffert on a vu des choses affreuses
là-bas vraiment affreuses Cres sur le
côté de la route c'était
[Musique]
terrible les choses horribles qu'on a pu
voir ces centaines de personnes
assassinées bombardées ou
brûlées tous s réfugiés avec des
poussettes des chevaux et des charrettes
et la lou vare qui les mitraillit ça SEM
le chaos et bloqu les
routes il Bombard
il ne fais aucune distinction on a vu
tant de mors sur le chemin de cadavres
pourris de civil de soldat de chevaux de
B n'importe quoi cétait absolument
épouvantable malgré toutes horreurs les
sold n pas le Cho de poursuivre le route
on de pvres jeunes se faire mettre en
pièce et on faisait plus
attentioné arrivé c'est
tout
c'était vraiment horrible de voir ces
femmes et ses enfants se faire blesser
mais on pouvait pas faire
grandchose c'est impossible de sauver
qui que ce soit quand on est en pleine
mission on rent du
désespoir fait son mieux mais onit qu'on
accom il y avit ce petit garçon qui est
rentré deéle et qui
mais est mort il demandait où est ma
mère il a fini par suivre les soldats
avec
nous ils avançaient avec leurs
charrettes leurs vélos et leurs
poussettes tout ce qu'on faisait c'était
soigner les pieds des paysans ils
avaient les pieds meurtris et notre
médecin lesit leur
bandit mes pieds étaient en très mauvais
état les soldats me portaient sur leur
dos parce que je ne pouvais plus marcher
je n'étais qu'une
enfant c'était horrible
mon père a renoncé il ne voulait plus il
a dit je n'irai pas plus loin les BES
peuvent
m'avoir c'est dans les profonds tunnels
s'étendant sous le château de Douvre que
les Britanniques commencent à élaborer
l'Opération Dynamo le grand responsable
de l'évacuation était le viceiral RAM
vieil homme de confiance de la Marine
qui a été placé dans une situation
extrêmement difficile il travaillait à
Douvre dans la salle de la dynamo du
château c'est d'ici qu'est parti le
message comme quoi l'Opération Dynamo
allait
commencer ce sauvetage n'a rien d'une
opération militaire ordinaire le vice
amiral ramé conçoit un plan d'évacuation
qui implique plus de 900
[Musique]
embarcations la lufte VA avait presque
entièrement détruit le port de
DKK le port était presque inutilisable
il restait
Plag le problème c'est que les navires
étai trop gros pour s'approcher des
plages car la mer y était très peu
profond c'était de vastes plages plat
jalonné de
Dun c'est génial pour se faire bronzer
mais si on essaie d'amener de gros
destroy jusqu'à la plage pour que des
hommes qui s'y trouvent mont à bord ils
ont découvert que c'était
impossible ce dont ils avaient besoin
c'était de plus petits bateau pour
transporter les soldats depuis les
plages jusqu'au grand navire militaire
et civil au large de la
côte le gouvernement britannique lance
un appel au propriétaires de petites
embarcations afin qu'il participe à
cette mission de sauvetage qui deviendra
la plus grande évacuation de l'histoire
militaire au grand mot les grands
remèdes l'appel a été lancé à la radio
c'est tout ce que les gens
savaient ce n'est que très tard pendant
l'évacuation que les journaux et la
radio ont rapporté qu'elle était en
cours ça avait été gardé
secret tout s déroulé très rapidement
ils ont réquisitionné les navires du
jour au lendemain c'était le CH organisé
Tux qui PV don coup de fa bien des
propriétairesign que leur bateau av
réquisitionn si le propriétaire TRV au
alentours il PV participer au sauvetage
sinon la marine prenait quand même son
bateau
plusieurs des soldats qui arrivent
épuisés aux abord dekerk n'ont pas mangé
depuis des
jours j'ai conduit pendant 48 he je
m'endormais au volant et je me
réveillais quand je frapp la bordure de
la route finalement je suis arrivé à la
plage je suis entré dans un café et j'ai
demandé sil P remplir no bouteilles
parceonait rien
àire plus d'eau à dunkererk les
Allemands ont fait sauter le réseau
d'eau elle m'a quand même offert de les
remplir de vin rouge alors on a bu du
vin rouge sur la
[Musique]
plage dunkerk est un véritable désastre
pour l'armée britannique qui y perd une
grande partie de son équipement
militaire à leur arrivé à donkirk les
soldats ont été surpris d'apprendre
qu'ils allaient devoir faire sauter leur
voiture leur char tout ce qu'ils avaient
utilisé pour se rendre là la grande
majorité de l'équipement que l'armée
britannique avait emporté en France a
été perdu il abandonner lourde et
presque tous les véhicules en France
parce cétait impossible de lesorter de
l'autre côté de la Manche il on l're de
mettre du sable dans les réserir à
essence pour faire bloquer les moteurs
parce qu'il ne fallait pas que les
Allemands puissent utiliser
l'équipement
[Musique]
une fois rendu à la plage le lieutenant
m'a dit tu es de l'armée de l'air et ces
hommes sont tous de l'armée de terre
s'il t'attrapent ils vont te tabasser
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais vu d'avion
venir les aider il m'a donc conseillé
d'enlever mes souliers et de mettre des
bottes
et un casque en
métal comme ça j'étais complètement
déguisé en soldat de
l'armé les dizaines de milliers de
soldats rassemblés sur le sable des
plages de dunkerk sont témoins de scènes
de destruction qu'ils n'oublieront
jamais tout éta en feu sur la
plage on se faisait attaquer par des
bombardiers et lesou descendaient en
piqué vers la plage les gens ne
s'imaginent pas ça mais mon dieu on
voyait t nos ais se faire pulvérisé des
navires explosés en
[Applaudissements]
morceaux on entendait les canons
ton on était impuissant sans endroit où
s'abritait on se coucha dans le sable je
me souviens que j'étais caché derrière
un grand ban de sable et je pouvais
entendre les balles le pénétrer de
l'autre côté il fallait se coucher dans
le sable cétait assz déplaisant les
chasseurs et les bombardiers survol la
plage sans arrê enillant aucun moyen de
protection alors on ass surble n part
juste où je me trouv sur la plage il n'y
avait pas d'officier du tout il fallait
qu'on se débrouille tout seul je me
rappelle pas avoir vu un officier là
c'était chacun pour so
le moral est au plus bas parmi les
troupes qui attendent les secours sans
ravitaillement et sans grand
espoir environ 4 jours sans nourriture
sans eau sans
rien il y en a je suppose qui ont fini
par abandonner je ne saaai
dire ce sentiment de désespoir ne quitta
jamais notre esprit on savait pas ce qui
allait se passer on était é incapable de
penser on demanda bien ce qui allait
arriver contraint d'attendre sous une
pluie de bombe les soldats sans défense
ont l'impression d'être abandonné par la
Royal Air
Force le sentiment général parmi les
soldats sur la plage était que la RF les
avait
abandonné la puissance de défense était
insuffisante où étai les canons
antiaériens il n en avait pas je n'ai
pas vu un seul avion Britan il n'ont pas
fait grandchose faut dire qu'onait pas
beaucoup
d'avion les soldats et les marins
critiqu la et le commandement des
chasseurs qui ne venaient pas les
défendre àk chaque fois qu'il leva les
yeux vers le ciel il ne voyait que des
Allemands où étaai dans la
R
des aviateurs dont l'avion avait été
abattu ou qui travaill au sol tent aussi
de monter à bord des navires pour
rentrer au
paysoussme attaqu par des gens qui leur
dis pas NZ rien fait pour nous aider il
à je TR ça pe
déplacé une fois r en Angleterre on a
que Laé les troupes sur la plage mais
pas sur notre plage
affaibli par les pertes subies durant la
campagne française la RF n'est pas en
mesure d'arrêter l'assaut aérien
allemand cela dit elle peut certes
l'entraver les soldats et les marins
Croy tout simplement que la RAF n'était
pas là ce qui était vraiment injuste
parce qu'elle était belle et bien
là peut-être pas au-dessus des plages
mais un peu plus loin sur terre ou en
mer bien sûr avec la bataille
d'Angleterre l'attitude envers les
membres de la RAF a changé ils sont
devenus les héros de la
nation pendant que les divisions
allemandes s'entassent autour de donkerk
le corps expéditionnaire britannique est
au bord de l'anéantissement son sort en
équilibre sur le fil du
rasoir le 27 mai 1940 le capitaine
William tenent officier supérieur de la
marine arrive à dunkerk pour coordonner
l'évacuation ten s'est rendu compte que
même si le port avait été détruit il y
avait quand même un long brise lame une
dig de protection elle n'avait
absolument pas été conçu pour qu'un
navire s'en
approche elle servait seulement à
empêcher le sable d'atteindre le port et
de
l'envaser il a immédiatement pensé à
faire amarrer les bateaux le long de
cette digue de protection pour que les
troupes soient ensuite en mesure de
monter à
bord il a fait avancer un bateau le long
de la digue pour voir ce que ça
donnerait et ça a
marché des centaines de bateaux dont
l'équipage est composé de membres de la
Royal Navy et des volontaires civils
traversent les EAU traîtresses de la
Manche plusieurs de ces marins assiste à
des scènes qui les marqueront à
jamais c'était horrible je n'avais
jamais vu quelque chose comme ça avant
plein de gens se faisaient
tuer les sters descendaient bou bou boum
boum sans
arrêt la majorité des petites
embarcations qui ont fait la traversée
avaiit été réquisitionné et étai piloté
par des membres de la Royal Navy qui
souvent n'avaient aucune idée de la
façon dont fonctionnaient ces bateaux
beaucoup d'entre eux ne savaient pas ce
qu'il faisait il y avait un bateau avec
60 personnes à bord quand il est arrivé
il flottait à bonne hauteur mais avec la
soixantaine de passagers il s'est
enfoncé l'eau arrivait à environ 60 cm
du PL
bord la raison d'utiliser ces petits
bateaux c'était d'amener les soldats des
plat jus'au plus gros navire au large de
la côte l'opération allait donc se
répéter main et main de
fois j'ai commencé vers 9h et j'ai
arrêté vers
16h j'avais environ TR voyages
allerretour pour aller chercher du
monde on essayait chaque fois de monter
sur les bateaux qui arrivaient mais il
se remplissait avant qu'on les
atteigne on a attendu sur cette digue
pendant une éternité pour avoir une
place dans un bateau on se faisait tirer
dessus
Seigneur on faisait des signes de la
main pour que les bateaux s'arrêtent
pour nous beaucoup d'entre pass tout
droit ma mère AG sa chemise de nuit elle
n'arrêtait pas de le faire des signes de
crier je suis
britannique les marins sont la cible des
attaques sans merci de
la
les bateaux se fais détruire à droite et
à gauche cétait comme entrer en
enfer on par à
l'opétionang je danseauam des av perdu
le jamb le pied pour les mettre sur des
canaux de fortune et les pousser vers
les
bateaux
il y avait de l'essence et du sang dans
l'eau et quelque chose de vert je ne
sais pas ce que c'était mais c'était et
ver onit fairecas par un Bau donéquipage
nait pasarqu la présence de sold dansau
il la
Meren qu gros bateau coulent leur moteur
explose et le diesel se retrouve partout
à la surface on pouvait facilement se
faire tirer dessus beaucoup de ceux qui
sont revenus morts sur les bateaux ont
été abattus ou bombardés dans l'eau par
les avions allemands beaucoup d'autres
n'ont pas survécu à la traversée quand
les premiers bateaux ont commencé à
rentrer en Angleterre ils ont soulevé la
barrière et ont vu un bateau arriver
dont la moitié des
passagers était
mort quand on est entré dans le port de
d'ouvre les gars nous ont tiré dessus
j'ai dû leur dire d'arrêter de tirer
qu'on était des Anglais on était plus
que 4 sur 12 au
[Musique]
départ alors que la bataille fait rage
sur terre en mer et dans le ciel les
hommes travaillent jusqu'aux limite
absolu de leur
endurance personne ne se parlait c'était
partez
partez tout le monde essayait de quitter
donkirk par quelque moyen que ce soit
quand les petits bateaux sont arrivés
ils on oup de G les gars prochain
arrê on était aux anges après ça on a PR
pr pr pour réussir à rendre
jus on a par trouver un
ch il y avait quelquun qui comp qui mon
àord c'est
maintenant je me suis couché et je me
suis endormi
aussitôt
ma mère a eu la bonne idée de dire on va
éviter les grandes embarcations parce
que les Allemands les bombardent sans
cesse on est doncé sur ce petit
pétrolier qui s'app le nous ont installé
dans la cabine du capitaine et nous ont
dit que le bateau pouvait être bombardé
à tout moment c'était très dangereux de
passer à travers tous ces débr on a d
traverser du feu pour en
sor temp les
bbesilleus d'autres s'en sont
tirés des bombes des bombes et encore
des bombes vous ne pouvez pas vous
imaginer cet enfer il fallait y être
pour y croire on entend toutes sortes de
balverne que certains ont dit qu'il
n'avait pas peur mais on pouvait
s'empêcher d'avoir
peur après ça on a prié et prié et prié
pour réussir à se rendre jusqu'àouvre et
on est effectivement rentré à Douvre
c'était merveilleux absolument
merveilleux le changr là le levé du
on était abattu complètement
abattu mais quelle sensation ça nous a
procuré d'être rentré en
Angleterre je la ressens
encore c'était un miracle et on était
heureux d'être en
vie compagnie compta 107 membres il en a
juste 31 qui sont rentrés sur 107
les soldats britanniques qui ont quitté
les plages de France au plus profond du
désespoir sont accueillis chez eux comme
des héros
[Musique]
conquérants on venait de perdre une
bataille mais le peuple d'Angleterre
nous traitait comme des
héros ce dont je me souviens encore
aujourd'hui ça a l'air de rien je sais
mais c'était incroyable pour nous quand
on est arrivé à har c'est qu'il y avait
des centaines de femmes sur les de toute
évidence elle s'était fait dire dès que
les navires entreront au port empoz un
soldat et occupez-vous de
lui debout sur le qu se trouv toutes ces
charmantes dames et ell voulait toutes
s'emparer des héros blessés comme
moi les femmes du Service Volontaire
féminin m'ont caus plus de problèm que
n'importe quel
allemand ESS tout de m'attraper médecin
m'a dit vous êtes encore en vie vous
faites
l'affaire une dame m'a pris par le bras
et m'a amené dans un hangar pour me
donner du thé et des
sandwich mon cilote qui avait survécu
lui aussi disait à tout le monde que je
lui avais sauvé la vie ce n'était pas
tout à fait vrai j'avais conduit le
camion pendant qu'il se salait à
l'arrière je l'avais amené jusqu'à la
plage et je l'avaisit sortir avant qu'on
abandonne le camion d'une certaine façon
on peut dire que je l'avais sauvé mais
pas
vraiment quand mon bataillon s'est
finalement réuni j'ai été surpris de
voir combien de ses membres avaient
réussi à revenir c'est un miracle qu'on
a réussi à sortir de là les gens étaient
très gentils quand on est arrivé en
Angleterre ils nous ont aidé et nous ont
donné des vêtements onait rien il a
fallu se déshabiller se laver et se
faire des
DKK pour moi ça a été une épopée de
bravoure absolue j'ai traversé l'enfer
pour sortir de l'enfer je suis revenu
sain et
sauf c'est c'est comme ça que je
vois l'Opération Dynamo est la plus
grande évacuation militaire de
l'histoire cette campagne permet
d'éviter de justesse la rédition de la
grandebr
ourant majeur de la Guerre mondiale mais
pour les soldats qui
revent4 les trpes britanni qui on étacu
se cons en quel Ste comme les vestiges
d'une armée vainc sold terriblefite il
son
r bien c'était une
évacuation on est monté sur un bateau et
c'est tout
céta des héros parce qu'ils avaient
survécu et ça signifia que la
GrandeBretagne avait un
aveniration
de Brit rest dans la
guerreour bien plus de
gens incroyable combien il
enourend pasver plus de 4000
hommes au bout du compte ils ont réussi
à retrouver et à ramener près de 340000
soldats l'armée britannique avait
survécu une euphorie patriotique
s'empare du public
britannique la fumée de la bataille plan
sur donk ce port de l'autre côté de la
Manche d'où rentrent des milliers
d'hommes du corps expéditionnaire
britannique la magnifique opération
d'arrière-garde menée par les armées
britanniques et françaises n' d'égal que
le splendide travail de la marine pour
protéger les soldats et les ramener chez
eux dans des navires de guerre et des
embarcations de toutes sortes ils se
battent sans cesse depuis 2 semaines et
le monde entier est émerveillé par leur
immense courage et leur discipline
inébranlable sous le brillant
commandement de leur supérieurs jamais
dans toute son histoire militaire la
Grande-Bretagne n'a-t-elle été aussi F
de ses fils
combattant la route sera encore longue
vers la victoire finale la Seconde
Guerre mondiale se poursuivra durantut
anné mais ce sont les événements de qui
rend possible cette grande marche vers
la
pai plusieurs ont pris quelques jours
pour
récupérer droit à
jours est
arrivous bien peur que le réveil soit à
6h
ici vu que vous étiez à
DK vous pouvez vous lever à 7h ou 8h et
prendre le déjeuner mais c'est
[Musique]
tout les hommes du corps expéditionnaire
profitent de quelques moments de r après
le retraite héroïque des Flandres ici
dans un camp de repos il se dépoussiè se
ressaisissent et se laissent aller à
chanter un peu
mon copain et moi on est rest ensemble
pendant toute la guerre on a tous les
deux survécu
à au moment de monter sur un bateau on
est allé dans des directions différentes
j'ai supposé qu'il avait été tué ou fait
prisonnier il a pensé la même
choseendemaintin
ing il m'a vu et est venu me serrer dans
ses bras comme si on avait été des
amants qui s'était perdu de vue depuis
longtemps on croyait tous les deux que
l'autre avait
péri on l'chapp belle tellement de fois
c'était absolument incroyable on était
dans un cinéma Jinju et moi regarder un
film dont j'ai oublié le titre quand la
salle a été touchée par une bombe plus
de 500 personnes sont mortes mais
on est sorti tous les deux de là tout
juste recouvert de
poussière l'Opération Dynamo a été
portée au grand écran à plusieurs
reprise la sortie de donkerirk du
réalisateur Christopher Nolen en 2017 a
une fois de plus attiré l'attention du
monde sur ces événements qui ont changé
le cours de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour moi c'est un des plus
grands moments de l'histoire de
l'humanité je suis très heureux que
certains des anciens combattants qui ont
vécu l'évacuation soi
ici le le film ça ét une des choses les
plus intimidantes que j'ai jamais véc en
tant cinéaste d'IR devant gens qui ont
vécu cet événement qui ont maintenant
plus de 90 ans pour le montrer notre
version de le
histoire ass à la première
de j'étais sur le tapis rouge les gens
venaient me faire un
câin il é des centaines derrière les
barrières qui s'pr appla nous
sal bon film mais les qui pe comprendre
comment
qui personne d'autre ne peutagin comment
céit
erreurs mineur que j'aurais pu lui
reprocher mais en général c'était assz
exact le prince Harry m'a invité au
palais quel homme
merveilleux mais je n'étais que le deè
homme le plus gé ça c'est
honte il nous ont traité en hér vousêes
destiez
toujours vous a aidé à monter la
colline une dame m'a poussé un petit
bout de temps ensuite quelqu'un est venu
du palais et m'a demandé savez-vous qui
c'était j'ai dit non c'était Kate je ne
pouvais pas le savoir il était derrière
moi il a vraiment été charmant le prince
Harry il est descendu et il nous a parlé
il est très
gentil je n'arrivais pas à mettre mes
souliers parce que j'ai les pieds qui
enflent j'ai dû y aller en pantoufle
j'ai dit au prince Harry excusez-moi
pour mes pantoufles il m'a répondu au
moins es sont bleu
royal le prince Harry nous a bien
remercié je dirais qu'on a été de vrais
héros et j'ai remercié le Seigneur je le
remercie
encore
[Musique]